bono mitternacht blüte die richtige show
bin ich dumm halte was mache ich denn es
wird in dem druck politik
was geht ab leute herzlich willkommen zu
ändern games ja okay es geht gleich los
mit dabei sind warum und raul und es
geht los
zumal dieses mysterium dass wir da
gerade das egal ereignet hat man zu
entschlüsseln
es war so dass raul einfach mal zu blöd
darum auf der teamspeak zu gehen
doch wir haben es geht er ich hab dir
ich hab ich schon bevor du geboren bist
schon geboren was habe ich da der mutter
gesagt heute am 48 den ersten werde ich
um 15 uhr 14 erwarten dass sein sohn auf
dem teamspeak ist und der dienstbarkeit
heißt xyz und damit auch der wehr ii
umgesetzt sein und ich weiß nicht mal
kurz beschrieben
es ist mein haushalt also ich bin schon
jetzt etwas gut ausgerüstet rund 100
eltern ein
diese finden ist so häufig die laufwerke
am sport hinterher junge sterben ohne
scheiß warum lebst du denn ich kann
komme ich mal vorbei so weiter geht es
bei mir unter ex-trainer das warum ist
so ein assi haut doch habt ganz ehrlich
was soll das das ist so asozial
nee ich leb noch aber du willst dann
herausfinden wo ich bin
ich werde mein gott oh mein gott
erstmal checken tecan tecan tecan nein
nein nein nein nein renne ich auf mich
wenn ich auf mich bitte nicht ich hab
das kann ich hätte mich total an sich
sehr gut ist ein kräftiger setzen
expect tätig erst mal schuhe
okay ich habe mir die runde nicht läuft
ihr wisst ja wichtigste ist es immer
helm und schuhe
ich glaube ich weiß nicht sagt mir ist
es eigentlich behindert und dumm dass
ich die kräftig tablets immer up 3d tvs
action leute ich muss schon sagen
ihr merkt ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt
ich freue mich mal wieder aufnehmen zu
dürfen
ich hab jetzt wie lange ich aufgenommen
kann es kommt mir wie eine ewigkeit vor
ich glaube es war nur einen tag oder so
viel spaß dass ich gar nicht mehr ohne
kann weiß nicht wo du bist
würde mal sagen die jungs tot ist und
ich werde ganz bestimmt ich damit
rechnen dass ich ende perlen wegwerfe
wird all das erinnert mit einem eisen
gespannt und das will nicht mal mental
gehen aha ich wurde mit v2 0 313
getauscht 93
hahahaha und die entweder mit pfizer
alter bin ich dumm bin ich eigentlich
dumm ich habe einfach die ganze kein
eisen schritt gemacht warum lag
vielleicht daran dass die stadt hat der
ist dann ist man auch mal jung reist und
so alles klar
ja hier ist ein chart table aber ich
kann nicht entscheiden weil ich nicht
genug erfahrung heaven to heaven sein
bin ich mit kid ausgewählt dass pro kit
damit gewinnt man automatisch er daran
ihr game hewitt
geil wie ich bin ich bin hunter glaube
ich ja ich bin und da ich krieg' ich
krieg mich gebratenes fleisch wenn ich
dinge killer
das gefällt mir das leben ob ich auch
gebratene wolle kriege
nein ich krieg einen teleporter nicht
und schafft keller schwer ein dia
was habe ich dir schwert da war ich
schon einen schritt weiter
erstmal ist es hier einfach nur in
diamant wenn die erschwert
naja da schauen wir wo der nächste es
141 blöcke 107 40 da kann man erstmal
chili malley 1
die erschwert machen das kann man machen
die kraft nicht gerade die crafting box
du bist ein richtiger mini kraft player
die crafting box kaufen ja unbedingt ein
neues pay kanal crafting box kräftigen
boxx-tv x3 hd hd kraftwerk verdient
nächstes jahr auf demokratie ist ob
jetzt schon wachsen kann leute was meint
ihr so nein so er nicht was sagt der
feri um keine beleidigung ich spreche
den namen einfach nur dumm und behindert
aus seiner vita wie du bist ich dachte
mir hinterher war der abschnitt nur
wirklich kaum größer wird vielleicht
sollte ich mir jetzt erstmal mit kräften
hier vielleicht mal so eine art test
plate finde ich ganz normal ich wollte
dir einfach mal hat die verhütung haben
die rohkost 19 in goslar auf keinen fall
ein massiv richtung haben wir großen
nicht die schatzkammer und dann sagst
mir altmeistern gut schlecht dann sagt
mir was sie haben und hat der fuldaer
oder wie und er gibt nach blüten mit
full die leute macht ja und hier ist
immer irgendwann hat
würde alter opa wieder mein schwert
weggeworfen
damit sollten ich war so überrascht dass
ich tatsächlich schaffen was drauf
bekommen hab ich's einfach weggeworfen
jung und wo das in welche richtung es in
der richtung er gibt doch diesen typ der
spd für die scheiße wertvoll die
galeristen dazu gar fast verloren aber
dafür entscheidet die er das hat er so
ein damage dealer einen typ hat auch in
kanada und die der jetzt hier bange ist
mit diesen argumenten kannst du kommst
du nicht wenn du unter ohne sein oder
auch mitternacht güte richtige schwung
bin ich dumm halte was gut getroffen
wurde so natürlich auch hier seht ihr
mich seht ihr mein geist seht ihr mein
geist immer wertet kein fall mehr haben
keine fassade baden hat war ja die erste
runde ende game set langem wirklich lang
ist es schon lange her also dem gesetz
männer ganz gezeigt habe und ja es war
sogar eine runde
das war unser erster tag eigentlich ganz
okay ich bin ich nicht so abgegangen
liegt daran dass ich wusste nicht ob
husten
ja okay leute ihr wisst ich habe heute
keine zwanzig geholt wie immer bei
husten hatte und ja dann würde ich sagen
gute besserung an mich gesund wenn ihr
mehr ändern games sehen wollte demnächst
mit merkel ins nächste runde mit
mindestens drei kills dann bei dem ende
games sehen wollt dann lasst schon jetzt
in die kommentare
lasst es mich wissen ob ich die wahlen
hat und zeigt es mir auch mit einem
daumen nach oben sky war daumen nach
oben ihr wisst ja wie es läuft wie seid
ihr alle schon youtube profis sozusagen
ihr meine gallen und besten und suiten
zuschauer und ja da würde ich sagen
verabschieden wir uns hier noch mal ein
herzliches dankeschön an
wer ihm unterhält places oder raul oder
bruce 1500 die hier mitgespielt haben
gerne mega swing von euch ab dass ich
wirklich wie ein wasserfall reden kann
das find ich kuh l und ja leute bevor
ich die abgabe vor wären wieder so ein
live act und sich einer wie er würde ich
mal sagen macht's gut leuten hausrat und